all right we have a trailer a new
trailer for Christopher Nolan's tenth
tenant I'm going to put another end in
there an extra end and I apologize if I
call it tenants it's just how I
naturally want to roll the word but
tenets you put an extra and in there
then you can't spell it forward and
backward and have it spelled the same
thing don't do that Jeremy you'll ruin
an idiot but then your trailer for
tenant really shows us what the first
trailer for tenant shows us is that
we're dealing with the story in which
time goes forward but also backward in
some instances for some people kenneth
branagh can apparently communicate with
the future which is funny because when I
worked at the theater I worked with this
Russian dude who would always pick apart
Russian accents and look that person
sucks that that person sucks at it but
Kenneth Branagh in that Jack Ryan movie
he was like it was actually good that
was a legit Russian accent so he says
now that I'm a master at Russian accents
it's just funny that he's playing a
Russian again I have to assume the
consensus is he's pretty good at it so
they're trying to prevent World War
three which I do like that World War
three is no longer seen is what will be
this nuclear holocaust that's so 80s
that's so Cold War because now I mean as
technology has grown it would probably
be something else so in a world where it
can be something else why not have it be
something like time going backward
because it also gets the curiosity
flowing as to how like how is that
execution going to happen in this noland
world it's no one's story the story of
this director who is known to be a
craftsman of imagination and this
trailer show there's a little more of
what was shown in the last trailer and
definitely mentioned in one scene
there's like what happened in this room
it hasn't happened yet well now we get
to see some of what hadn't happened yet
which is bullets going backwards into
guns rather than being shot from guns
which means the only thing more fun than
seeing the footage go backwards in the
trailer as it's going forward is
reversing the footage in a YouTube video
watching it go backward which means it's
going forward I don't know I just get a
kick out of it it's probably do the
whole video like this but I like about
Nolan is he's always been good at taking
these extraordinary scenarios you know
these concepts like we saw an
interstellar with relativity and how he
Illustrated that like we saw in
Inception Nolan's always been pretty
good at taking something complicated and
making it accessible in his movies is
accessible for the average moviegoer to
be like God but in wondering how he's
going to execute time going backwards
like is it going to be a can the future
affect the past kind of scenario this is
great episode of this
called through the wormhole in which I
think the title is can time go backward
because more three dimensional beings
going what we perceive is forward
through what we perceive as time so we
see action reaction rinse and repeat as
we go one direction but what if the
reactions are actually the actions and
the actions are the reactions what if
time goes backwards simply put if you
drop a plate it shatters on the ground
now the plate shattered because you
dropped it or did you drop it because
the plate was shattered in the future
question for the philosophers so is it
gonna deal with something like that it's
fascinating but I don't know but this is
what I like about Christopher Nolan
trailers there are a lot of trailers out
there where you see the trailer and
you're like I know exactly what the
movie is about but Christopher Nolan
trailers you have the gist but you don't
usually know the the meat and bones of
the actual plot where some directors
don't have creative control over their
trailers which is how you get dubstep in
the warcraft trailer you feel like no
one has a lot of control over the
trailer if it was something that he
wouldn't want you ever really be like
nope and it'd be like yes sir mr. Nolan
alright take it a seat right here we
have a table right here waiting for you
gar Saul fix him up with anything he
would like we will get that fixed full
everything that Nolan does is just feel
like that's definitely Nolan and how we
wanted to do it that or he just gives
whatever company cuts two trailers
together enough this is what you get to
know and I do wonder in a world where
you know we live in a world of causality
one thing leads to the next thing did
interstellar directly influenced him to
make Tennant interstellar dealt with
space-time and relativity but still
going forward until the very end but I
wonder if that was a springboard of him
going re I want to look into more of
that and we'll deal with something else
that has to do with time but time going
backward now I don't know maybe I'm
projecting because interstellar was kind
of it was a thing for me it really was
here's a story I'll try not to make it
too long we don't want to make this some
big indulgent piece but it's a story
nonetheless interstellar was kind of a
big deal for me because I watched
interstellar and then I liked it but I
had things to say about it people in the
comment section had things to say about
the things I had to say about it and
instead of doing due diligence and
looking into it you know looking into
the science my spoiler talked video I
did what youtubers should never do which
is double down and some act of hubris
the dunning-kruger effect my friends
were all susceptible we're all capable
of falling in
you don't know that much about something
know enough to know that you don't know
that much
you'll be say for the most and someone
in the comments section bless them the
comment was something along the lines of
maybe you don't know as much about this
as you think you do I remember seeing
that we unlike maybe I don't maybe I
should look into it and from there
started me down what I would call a
mental quest of gross cosmos Neil
deGrasse Tyson Carl Sagan Stephen
Hawking have all been influential
figures in my studies of space-time
reality the universe itself and my quest
to understand it all and now I know that
much that's so much more than I knew and
you realize by the end of your life you
won't have even scratched the surface
but it's not about knowing everything
it's just in these studies this is why I
essentially tell the story it gives you
a perspective that I don't think is an
exaggeration to say that it's
life-changing as I heard Carl Sagan say
it's a humbling and character-building
experience and totally true so I
encourage anyone out there look into it
study thirst to know how the universe
works and once you start down the path
forever will it dominate your destiny in
the best way possible it was a very big
moment interstellar was that thing for
me but also that comment which does show
the power of constructive criticism over
[ __ ] I think that person for that
calmness so maybe I'm just projecting
because interstellar was that thing for
me I'm like well maybe interstellar
springboards on to this I don't know
regardless I'm interested to see what he
does with tenets and how he deals with
time going backwards as well as forward
but have you seen the trailer what do
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and what's a
movie that influenced you in your life
and kind of inspired you to research and
grow it you know that movie I'd love to
hear what that movie is for you so again
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you
[Music]